the guests appearing on the program and
do not necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
[Music]
we see a gender divide within the state
politics now who is leading the race to
take office in 2022 our latest polling
reveals the top candidates and leading
issues on voters minds plus
and we've got to look for those things
that we should no longer be spending
money on and cut them from the budget
republican congressional candidate mark
robertson we have an extensive interview
on the economy abortion immigration and
more
[Music]
from eight news now
this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler we start
with our latest eight news now emerson
college of the hill exclusive poll it
shows razor thin margins in nevada's
biggest races the polling also shows the
economy is still king with the general
election a few months away the campaigns
are gearing up for this final push for
votes but the big races in nevada are
only getting closer
it's a one-point race spencer kimball is
director at emerson college polling he's
as surprised as you may be with results
of our new glimpse at november's biggest
races we're seeing a high number of
undecideds and people voting for none of
the above 8 news now focused on two of
the campaigns getting the most attention
and the most money senate and governor
first in the race for senate our poll
shows a statistical dead heat republican
challenger adam laxalt leads with just
under 42 percent incumbent democrat
catherine cortez masto now trails with
just over 41 percent for the senator
that's a three percent drop from our
last poll in july undecided voters are
up from nine to 11 percent however the
poll also shows this unusual statistic
we asked which candidate do you think
will win not who do you want to win
senator cortez masto holds a 54 to 46
percent lead as opposed to like building
up their candidacy they're kind of
taking down the other candidacy and
that's what's keeping those numbers and
it's not moving voters from one
candidate to the other it's moving them
more into that undecided group the race
for governor remains tight governor
steve sisolak leads by just .2 percent
with a three-point drop from july
republican challenger joe lombardo saw
only a small decrease both are now
around 40 percent however 52 percent of
those polled still think governor
sisilak will win re-election we think
it's important not just to hear how that
person's voting but what their circle of
friends are thinking
the election is uh less than 56 days
away from now so let's zoom in on the
senate race a little bit here our
polling shows a bit of a racial divide
for the two candidates democratic
senator catherine cortez masto as you
see here wins with black voters by about
27 points she was also winning latino
voters by 19 points that's actually a
bit closer than she would probably like
republican challenger adam laxalt
winning with white voters by nine points
in nevada we also asked a generic
congressional ballot question do you
plan to vote for a republican or a
democrat republicans held a three-point
lead in our polling that indicates the
mood in the country is still in the
gop's favor right now
and we looked at the issues what are
signs what are the concerns rather than
nevada voters are concerned about what
are the issues well they're changing
first let's get this out of the way we
do have the top issue that's the economy
spencer kimball is executive director of
emerson college polling it comes as no
surprise to him the economy matters most
to nevadans nearly 42 percent of those
we polled are voting based on the
economy that's around 9 percent higher
than our poll in july abortion comes in
second an issue kimball says is driving
the democratic vote on the democratic
side it's abortion access on the
republican side we see the search of mar
largo as a motivator another big issue
our decreasing water supply nearly 90
percent call it either very or somewhat
serious however there is another split
on education issues 39 support using
public money for vouchers for private
schools 33 percent are against while 18
percent are undecided and polls show 60
percent of nevadans are against
president biden's new student loan
forgiveness plan the mail vote is
breaking for republicans the female vote
is breaking for the democrats and we'll
see if either side is able to coalesce
the other group over in the next seven
eight weeks
you can see more on our exclusive poll
including we dig into even more issues
and look ahead to the potential 2024
presidential race that's at 8newsnow.com
now we've been trying to host debates
here at politics now and on channel 8.
on october 8th we're going to air a
congressional district 4 debate between
democrats stephen horsford the incumbent
and republican challenger sam peters
however candidates for district 3
they've both declined in district 1
republican challenger mark robertson did
agree to a debate democratic incumbent
congresswoman dina titus did not now we
want to reward people who are willing to
answer our questions for you the voter
so much of this show will be a sit-down
interview that i did with robertson this
week
let's get right into things right here
the number one issue for voters right
now you've probably heard of yourself
it's the economy food prices are up
inflation
has been rising
what's the first thing that you would do
if you're elected into congress to try
and improve our economy and improve the
situation yeah so to uh to fix inflation
you got to know what led to inflation
and what led to inflation was excessive
government spending and
and then we shut down the supply chain
and we were paying people not to go to
work so to reverse those the reverse
inflation you got to reverse those
policies you've got to stop
printing borrowing and spending money we
don't have you've got to stop the
wasteful government spending and then
you've got to give people incentives to
go back to work stop paying people not
to go to work
and then do all that you can to open up
that supply chain so the supply of goods
are happening we've seen interest rates
go up which is an effort to try and slow
the economy down and sort of level the
situation a little bit here um
there has been spending in government
for as long as government's been around
and the previous presidential
administration spent a lot of money as
well what is it specifically about the
bite administration's spending that
concerns you the most well if you if you
look at what was supposed to be
coveted relief funds covered relief
funds went to bail out cities and states
cities and states are so flushed with
money in fact
much of that bailout money came to
cities and states that already were
flushed with money they didn't need the
money
and then and then a lot of the
so-called coveted relief money went to
people who never lost their job you know
government workers federal government
workers never missed a paycheck
yet they got stimulus money so that's
this this excessive money that went out
to people and to governments um and
spent by governments in wasteful ways
now obviously that money has been sort
of spoken for at this point it's been
spent let's try and think of moving
forward you're elected to congress you
you take over the seat here
in the future down the line how do you
in your as you're saying bring that back
yeah so we've got to stop this
broken budget process where they wait
till the last minute they haven't passed
the budget so they just lump everything
together into something called a
continuing resolution or an omnibus bill
where it's all one big
big ball of budget that nobody's really
taken a look at and spent a detailed
look at what's inside that budget we've
got to get back to regular order where
the congress committees are looking at
every line on the budget and saying is
this a program we still need is this
what we should still be spending money
on is this one of our priorities
and we've got to look for those things
that we should no longer be spending
money on and cut them from the budget
let's switch gears and talk about
another major issue in the country right
now abortion it's been a major issue for
a long long time there's a proposal in
congress right now a 15-week abortion
ban is that something you're in favor of
no i am not in favor of any federal
federal legislation on abortion
the decision to overturn roe said that
there is nothing in the constitution
about abortion and when the constitution
is silent on a on a topic then that
means that the power rests with the
states and we the people and that's
where it should be resolved and that's
where it has been resolved in nevada in
nevada abortion is a settled
issue it is law
and
and i i am opposed to the federal
government taking power from we the
people and bringing it up to the federal
government which brings up the recent uh
proposal by senator lindsey graham a
federal abortion man he himself admits i
don't think he expects it to pass
is that obviously something you're not
in favor of that i would not be in favor
of the federal government taking paid
power from the people not a political
point of view but as on a human level
what is your stance on abortion oh i'm
i'm uh unapologetically pro-life i think
we ought to
protect the life of unborn children
i'm with 71 percent of the americans who
say that we ought to have
limits on abortion
my opponent has taken the extreme
position that there should not be any
limits that the abortion should be
available up to the hour before a baby
is born and that the government should
pay for that
she's not listening to the will of
people 71 percent of the people say
there should be
limits on abortion
the limits i would place first i think a
woman should have the choice whether or
not she engages in activities that lead
to pregnancy
so when she doesn't like in the case of
rape or incest that would those should
be exceptions i would also support
exceptions in case of the life or health
of the mothers
at risk
just to correct myself regarding the
candidates not willing to take part in
debates in congressional district three
the incumbent democrats suzie lee did
agree to a debate but her opponent april
becker did not
next on politics now solving the crisis
at the border up next we'll speak with
mark robertson again about what he would
change down there
the governors who are flying immigrants
to places like martha's vineyard and
legally
let's go places
welcome back to politics now
tonight we are interviewing republican
congressional district one candidate
mark robertson here i asked him about
immigration policies at the border
let's talk about the border
you've said in a previous interview
you've done with us that the u.s needs
to close the border the southern border
with mexico
recently republican governors
along the southern border have been
sending
some people who've crossed to
washington d.c new york city martha's
vineyard do you support that sort of a
an event first i want to clarify i
didn't say we should close the border we
have a very um
busy border between us and mexico lots
of commercial activity going before
these women i thought we should secure
the border we should stop the illegal
flow of guns gangs and drugs coming
across our border
but your question is more specific on
the governor abbott or or the governor
of florida's run
sending some of these people who have
crossed our border illegally into other
sanctuary cities i think it's a clever
idea i think we
we are struggling to get our national
leaders to get the vice president the
president to come down and see what's
going on on our border and so delivering
those
people who have crossed illegally into
washington dc or new york city or any
other sanctuary cities
helps those
leaders who
need to see what the problem is and
experiences aside from this this effort
this endeavor to send some of these
people from the from who have been taken
from the border across the border
illegally to other states to kind of
sort of show them what's going on down
there what else if you're elected to
congress would you do to change the
circumstances on the southern border
right now yeah so i would finish the
wall i would secure the building the
border by finishing the wall and wear
walls not practical using electronic
monitoring giving border patrol
the resources they need to enforce our
laws i would reinstate now
obviously congress can't do all of this
if the president has to cooperate i
would
reinstate the remaining in mexico policy
and i would end the policy of catch and
release where peop where people who
cross our border illegally have no
consequence for doing so so i would and
then i would enforce our border laws
once you've done that then we need to
talk about fixing our broken immigration
system the mechanism of immigration and
legal immigration what do you believe
should be done yeah so it our system's
broken now by the way i'm
pro-immigration i would not be sitting
in this chair if my great-grandparents
great-great-grandparents had not
immigrated to this country and that goes
for most americans so i believe most
americans favor immigration we need it
as a country if you just look at our
social security system it relies on
current workers funding the social
security of retirees we need more
workers and so we but we ought to decide
who comes into our country it shouldn't
just be hordes who break our laws and
come in here we ought to decide but we
ought to make it easier for those who
have the skills and the talents
to come into our country legally
how many legal immigrants should be
allowed into the country each year i
don't know that i don't know an exact
number
but but i would imagine it's a large
number again we have a large number of
retirees who depend on
current workers supporting them and we
and as i talk to business
business owners throughout southern
nevada
they're concerned about inflation but
really their biggest concern is they
don't have enough people to hire and
there are people around the world with
skills that we need that are willing to
come to our country so if if it's legal
you don't think there should be a cap
necessarily well there probably needs to
be
some kind of cat there needs to be some
i don't know what that number would be
because i don't know
the uh total demand of labor we have i
mean right now we've got
what 30 three million un unfilled
positions that are going without
workers so maybe that's a starting point
you look at how many unfilled positions
we have
next on our interview with mark
robertson congressional candidate we
talk about education if it's time to
reconsider using yucca mountain for
nuclear waste and debates
plus more support for an effort to break
up clark county school district we'll
tell you who's on board now
before you buy anything ever
you're watching politics now
tonight we're speaking with republican
congressional district one candidate
mark robertson we spoke about education
yucca mountain and debates
would you favor passing a national
school choice bill
no again i don't think the federal
government should have any role in
education if you look in the
constitution that doesn't mention
education at all as a role for the
federal government i would disband
i would abolish the us department of
education and then take the 86 billion
dollars a year that they spend and block
granted back to the states in the form
of vouchers that parents could use to
decide which education option is best
for their child you don't find the
department of education is a valuable
federal resource i do not okay the
states can do it better i believe so i
believe that's where it belongs i
believe that's what the constitution
says let's talk about something you're
familiar with military service of course
and recently there's been a lot of
money that has gone to ukraine recently
from the united states and from other
allies
do you think congress needs to authorize
any future wars or invasions absolutely
i do i think i think
congress has abdicated their role
they have given it to the executive
branch and that's not in accordance with
our constitution congress needs to take
back that role congress speaks for we
the people and the people ought to have
a voice in saying whether or not we send
our young men and young women off to
foreign lands to fight and die so how
would congress if you're elected get
that power back from the executive
branch yeah so we need we need to we
need to revoke the authority we've given
to the executive branch through through
legislative action uh revoke the
authority we've given to the legislative
branch and then
not fund wars that uh the executive
branch of the president wants to put us
in we control the purge congress
controls the purse only
fund those uh
wars or engagements that we the people
the representative have authorized one
issue that's very important to us here
in nevada of course is yucca mountain
this has been volleyed back and forth
for a long long time if you're elected
to congress
what would your stance be if there is
legislation proposed or efforts made to
try and use yucca mountain for nuclear
waste again yeah so i would work closely
with the the governor and the state
senate and the state assembly
because they should have a voice in this
the the leaders of our state should have
a voice in this but i am
in favor of taking a look at again
seeing if technology has changed if
safety measures have improved if
and see what the economic benefit to
nevada would be
to
to either building nuclear facilities
here so it doesn't have to be
transported or opening it up for waste
so you're open to the idea of nuclear
waste being brought to yucca mountain
i'm open to the idea of exploring it and
seeing and
but also making sure that nevada leaders
have a voice in that because in the past
it's kind of been like a green
a blanket no that's right it's not a
blanket no there haven't been really any
necessarily debates top to bottom
why
what is the how do you believe that
whether it's through this or other ways
that you can try and convince
independents to cross over that's been a
big challenge from the last couple of
elections for republicans in nevada yeah
i'm very disappointed that my opponent
wouldn't accept your offer to debate
you offered me and dina titus the
opportunity to debate and we accepted
immediately
and she wouldn't do it you know she
currently has an ad going uh running
that ends with her saying i won't back
down from a tough fight
well she's back down from this tough
fight she won't sit on this stage with
me
and answer questions she she's she's
she's
saying a lot of things right now that
just aren't true
and i don't think she would do that if
she and i were sitting here together say
things to me that weren't true when i
had a chance to answer
we have more with mark robertson on
topics like the student loan forgiveness
plan and the ukraine situation that is
at eight newsnow dot com we also have
previous interviews with his opponent in
the race the incumbent congresswoman
from democrat dina titus a northern
nevada man plans to plead guilty to
taking part in the january 6th capitol
hill attack the justice department says
that man there josiah kenyon will be
sentenced in mid-december court
documents say he used a large plastic
pylon and what appeared to be a table
leg to assault officers during the riot
a separate defendant from nevada had a
plea deal pushed back also this week
another political news democratic
treasurer zach conan has filed a
complaint with the secretary of state's
office against his republican opponent
michelle fiore conan says fiore and
former las vegas city councilman ricky
barlow formed a business together and
didn't disclose it barlow as you may
remember was convicted of stealing
campaign funds fiori recently touted his
endorsement of her he is a democrat
a potential 2024 ballot initiative to
break up clark county school district
has new support the communities and
schools initiative says it is now
endorsed by six major chambers of
commerce including the vegas urban latin
and asian chambers
organizers are in the process of
collecting enough signatures to get this
effort on the 2024 ballot the
legislature could also just pass it
themselves in 2023
sheriff and republican gubernatorial
candidate joe lombardo had some high
profile help on his campaign trail this
week virginia governor glenn younkin the
pair held a forum on lombardo's
education plan this week at liberty
baptist church lombardo wants to repeal
a new state law that makes it harder to
expel violent students lombardo also
says if he's elected he would restore
the read by third grade program
neither gentleman took questions from
the media democratic governor steve
sistelak's team criticized the church
where this event was held for its stance
on abortion
he's definitely not for nevada
[Music]
this week in what to watch a
congressional district 4 debate channel
8 will host a debate between democrat
incumbent democrats stephen horsford and
republican sam peters that'll be october
8 at 8 o'clock it'll be hosted by our
own christian kazadis and vanessa murphy
hopefully you'll be able to join us for
that
that'll do it for us here on politics
now we thank you so much for watching
stay up to date on all the political
news online at 8newsnow.com we're back
with you every saturday thank you for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
you